I just pulled some random [__] shitty
Clips too shitty Dino sketches what I
Googled too and you [__] were like oh
that was really cool yeah not to get a
good attention
[Music]
okay uh this is a little embarrassing
sometimes when you're hosting the show
it's not the best if you do the job
fully so I'm gonna ask that Nick Dunn oh
God reads this title I don't think I'm
capable of selling it in the way that I
think only Nick Dunn could possibly this
is a lot of pressure we're gonna do it
you gotta do a German accent then is
that what it is I don't know read it all
right Nick I'm gonna take my time
because I'm gonna put my yeah you're
fine
this 10 year old boy makes art that
sells for over one hundred thousand
dollars
oh [__] that was a specific Nick gun
title Nick Dunn had to read that title
yeah really why because to me it's like
10 year old boy make sure that it was
for a hundred thousand dollars
and you're fine I didn't nail it I'm
sorry I'm bad at playing yourself yeah
yeah how could you fail some research
this man so this kid that's awesome dude
I gotta show you guys this [__] that's
ridiculous so he lives in San Diego
California
well is he we'll find out does the art
make you feel something I don't know you
guys you guys are gonna tell me I'm
actually gonna not pass judgment I'm
gonna be good remember you spend a
thousand dollars on a hoodie two of them
I spent twenty thousand dollars on a
dinosaur
um egg so like chill out
the hoodies are nothing to me nothing
uh one sec one sec one sec all right I'm
gonna take out the price tag because it
might bias me I'm just gonna see if the
art is good first okay so tell me what
you guys think
about this
okay no way look dude if someone's
willing to pay a hundred thousand
dollars for that well go for it yeah I
gotta like it are you trolling us with
that one are you trolling us with that
one here I don't believe this Bart the
dad is coming up yeah hold on well that
also looks like my art have you guys
seen The Bee in the hallway that's you
that's me should I go get it it's a bar
Corner no it's on the wall but if you
get a chance when you walk to that
hallway on the right on the floor
there's a bee on the floor oh you see
that basketball flying or on the on the
door yeah that's me too
my original so I kind of respect genius
when I see it are you selling them I
think you suck who painted that [__]
over there the sun yeah hey
that's what I'm saying
all right nice Talent all right hundred
thousand dollars
oh that one doesn't even have color
though
that one needs he did no it's line art
it's actually pretty cool All the Rage
now and he did hit the borders he hit
all the borders so he filled up the Gap
would you spend a hundred thousand
dollars on this how big is it it's big
hey what the
Soul congratulations sold it's
[Laughter]
get the new car that's sick and then let
us know yeah let us know that's sick
though no let us know once the lift kit
is in the new car
make sure it has the lights to the
floodlight before this is there a story
with his drone like it let's say that
the story is at these are the drawings
that he did while he was kidnapped
yeah something [__] cool like yeah
yeah yeah what do you guys think about
this one that one's cool if he's just
doing this [__] the way that we were all
drawing that one's experimental is it is
he just a really good marketer is that
why he's getting all this hype is that
what you think I think so who's his dad
[__] Daniel sotheby Bart is that how
you pronounce that so this is the
auctioneers yeah
in my I read Sotheby's I thought it was
Sotheby's but this is I don't know [__]
I'm uncultured softy
that one's kind of cool too I like that
one I knew you would what so this is a
bar test Bart failed the test this is
the kids art
no way yeah that's worth 100 Jesus very
Picasso but see Bart forgave every
[__] moment of it that was pretty
sick I just pulled some random [__]
shitty Clips dude there's shitty Dino
sketches what I Googled to and you
[__] were like oh that was really
cool yeah not the kid of good attention
but he also likes this one for 10 years
old holy [__] crazy that's insane yeah
10 year olds are way more advanced and I
think because of the current host is
doing an okay job uh I read this article
so I think that there is context to
answer your question oh thanks Anthony
so uh it was parallel to like uh
Guernica and Picasso like using like
wartime and stuff like that to be
inspired this kid was actually building
art and stuff off of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine that's not why
that one's really cool it is why so it's
on some borderline and Frank [__] it's
actually that one yeah it's on some
borderline just you know it's actually
pretty cool yeah so he's in Ukraine in
San Diego oh he's San Diego San Diego
yeah what's that the Ukraine I'm just
saying inspired by like you know tragic
wartime type stuff but no he apparently
he just he just saw some cool DVDs and
like he just they came from that some of
us want to report the news here you know
isn't that cultural appropriation
Anthony is just making sure that I'm
saying the facts so that we you know are
saved
yeah oh that was crazy our fans don't
even know what DVDs are he said he has
some cool Hollywood videos that his dad
still has he just did this off for that
I don't like that one yeah I like the
other one that one looks like that one
looks like his mom's mom's Anglers like
I'd say this was only 30 G's or
something nah 30g these are very
impressive but that looks like it could
be big like it goes across your whole
living room but yeah no this kid so this
kid's kind of like a big [__] thing
right because
um you know his dad's Hollywood videos
are like pretty inspirational no yeah so
he so he was
um he was watching about the war in
Ukraine
the mom says not the dad
um and he saw a small 12-inch banana
scan canvas sketch and colored marker
and
um
the then the the dad was like Hey like
what's this and he says this is the
invasion of Ukraine and then the father
got moved by that and then the
the um the mom says that her art like
her kid is 10 years old and she was
asking about like why this happened and
like what's up with that and he's and
he's like hey can I have more room to
paint with so she got him so he's like
can you please leave yeah I mean yeah
um so then the prince of invasion of
Ukraine went up for sale on his website
and all the proceeds went to a
foundation which supports Ukrainian
youth and so now that's cool yeah now
um his work is getting a lot of
attention obviously because of that
little hook
um and he sold his entire 17 painting
collection in three days for for prices
ranging from five thousand dollars to
twenty thousand dollars wow so yeah he
sold it for over a hundred thousand
dollars obviously for like he did 17
paintings so do you think this do you
think this craze of physical paintings
in the real world is gonna catch on
no I think entities is what's up
look I need to know that I bought
something and then I need to know that I
can't sleep until I sell it
how about that how about that so you
don't believe in physical art is that
you're telling me it it it it's just
[__] fat bro I need something that
appreciates and depreciates quickly it
does both anytime you want it goes ups
and down and up and down when it comes
to the medium of sorry please no please
like a paint on canvas or whatever on
some sort of like picture portrayal or
something what's your guys's like go-to
favorite style of stuff starting titties
okay what titties starting titties tiny
tits art have you seen that signing a
breast like like um have you seen that
no like football players will get a
marker sometimes and chicks like hey
it's on my tits and then
I started Happy Gilmore is that your
question I thought your question is
about like what would you hang in your
kitchen or something
I was just gonna say what do you like
maybe it's like uh still life realism
abstract modern
um I don't think I'm smart enough to
give you a right answer
can I tell you one of my favorite pieces
pastel pink color pencil got some of my
favorite pieces of Art Tiger's drawings
no no
[Laughter]
Fairfax not one of those like art walk
things what was it it's the 3D ones no
the four Ninja Turtles and the heads are
the the office huh it's pretty cool
right oh that's pretty tight yeah so I
like stuff like that classify under I
think okay t-shirt designs okay
that's pretty sick
just wait I'ma hang it up so that's the
end of my intellectual conversation dude
I'm not smart enough to know the
different styles of art you don't have
to know that you ever just explain what
you like have you ever seen something
you liked the prestige I love that movie
Pastiche Prestige I saw some Van Gogh
[__] exhibit couple months ago that
was pretty cool is that the one that's
immersive yeah what was cool about it
it's just the music and [__] the French
just not the art the French music with
the the pictures and more pictures
um not like they would uh overlay his uh
his art across the ceilings and stuff
like so you like immersive Interactive
small big I like his style his style is
really cool van okay cool man what's
your favorite thing go the um
don't say starry night no it's not
starry night it was it was actually like
it was I forgot what it's called but
it's like a farm and it's in the day but
it's kind of like starry night but in
the day I don't say Farm day sunny day
farmy day farmy day don't say Training
Day Training Day
PCP that was like farmy day what's your
favorite art thing yeah fancy mofo yeah
you fancy little I'm kind of basic I
think um
all right what I only like things from
the Baroque era
kind of basic [__] you like dude if it
ain't Baroque don't fix it all right
anyways you are a classy [__]
dude like for example when I see like
modern art that's like really like oh
like what does it make you feel I don't
[__] get it yeah so I don't like
gravity towards it I'm not saying
anything like bad about me you don't
like [__] Splash [__] random [__] you
know what I mean or like it looks like
kind of like a kid could have done it in
a smaller figure I'm like I don't feel
good but I'm not hitting on it but when
I see that very classic when you go to
the museum you see like oil on canvas
and it's like you know old school like
you know Greek mythology or like you
know random shot or semi-realistic
paintings of [__] half nude people
that are like in Wartime and stuff yeah
that's [__] fun to me I feel like
it's a giant story you know what I mean
the oil on canvas it's like a giant
where's Waldo and you're like oh what's
what's happening but it's like a [__]
ton of wild [__] going on right there's
like a kid that's [__] being bathed
by wine over here someone's always half
naked somebody's getting like yeah like
their head chopped they're all metaphors
for stuff yeah yeah I bet this is
Anthony's favorite pieces are [__]
pipe cleaner [__] pipe cleaner
what a piece of [__] huh
I bet Anthony loves this [__] huh from
this from this seat in the house is the
best because Anthony's explaining what
he really likes and I just see [__]
Steve just like yeah yeah just typing
away and I'm like oh I can't wait for
the [__] punch line [__] this guy huh
it's the best
[Music]
foreign